you see Oklahoma running back Joe Mixon
did have his pro day yesterday and Joe
joins us now what do you think how do
you think you performed at the pro day
Joe could have been better but I was
fine with my performance at the end of
the day it was basically me going out
there I hadn't followed my teammates for
the last time how much pressure did you
feel yeah but you know that not being
invited to the combine and then you got
all these people who are there for the
pro day and like I don't know did you
feel like it was a benefit that you
didn't go to the combine and you had
this pro day that people focused on a
little bit more pressure I feel like it
was just another opportunity really I
think get it the first time at the
combine so luckily I was able to get it
you know for progress did you prepare
more for the actual athletic part of the
pro day or the interviewing I really
didn't prepare for anything this was
going out there and training we
basically been trained there for about a
month and a half two months and you know
I was going out there to have fun again
know like I said on my teammates for a
long time how many interviews did you do
yesterday with teams not too much
probably about six maybe what was the
one question that everybody asks you the
one question that everyone asks me I
really felt like they were really just
trying to get to know me as a person
they weren't really asking you know too
many questions about our incident
but I feel like for the you know for the
most part they were just trying to get
to know me
how many wanted to know if there were
other incidents in your past
are there any other incidents that they
don't need to know about and I'll
totally straight up there's okay besides
the two that they know about with that
in mind though how surprising is it to
you that you put yourself in a position
if you never had any incidents like this
because that's quite an incident a
moment that you had correct I take full
responsibility for that I could take it
back I will
[Music]
you know things will be interesting I
feel like you know things didn't happen
but unfortunately they did and I have to
deal with it hopefully is good better
the others just you know cute grind it
was for the best
how would things be different if that
didn't happen well what would your draft
stock be like where do you think that
you would be taken I will hope top 15
pick where do you put yourself with
these other running backs are you the
best running back country there are a
lot of good running backs but I really
feel like I'm number one how many teams
have told you or your agent that you're
not going to be on their draft board I
really haven't got any notifications
about being off anyone's job or my agent
or sure probably got a couple but for
the most part I feel like we've been
getting interest from a lot of teams if
you had the opportunity to draft you why
would you draft you
if I had the opportunity yeah let's say
you're the GM of a team and you're
looking at okay you know you with what
happened and your talent why why would
you take Joe Mixon I'm a great teammate
that's first and foremost I try to do
anything I can to bring energy to the
team
I try to do whatever I can to be the
best teammate I could be I try to push
my teammates to greatness at the end of
the day for the most part I will
basically want to as soon as I get
drafted at the end this day every time
I've got to work for sure I know I got a
lot of things to prove to people I love
to bring energy to the team and
hopefully we'll go out and won a Super
Bowl and that's what I'm aiming for what
would you say to the fans and you're
gonna have to say this to the fans who
aren't going to be able to get past that
video I respect I respect how they feel
I can't get past the video it's hard I'm
the one who did it
unfortunately I'm gonna have to live
with it I just you know I wouldn't well
I wouldn't keep dwelling on the past
I'm happy three and a half or three
years ago and it was just I just I would
do that I would keep dwelling on you
know being something that happened three
years ago I understand that it happened
unfortunately and I can't take it back
I mean if I could I would at the end of
the day I'm sorry
you know for you know the people that's
affected by it I'm sorry to the girl at
the end of the day is just something I
gotta live with unfortunately and I just
try to deal with it the best best way
possible
what have you done in the last couple of
years though after this that is it was
there
therapy rehab anger issue did you have
to go through any any classes anything
required
being white was I have to do a lot of
community service I have to do anger
management
am I still seeking it still trying to go
around the community and do anything I
can you know just a better myself as a
person I just want you know people are
really better I'm trying trying to be
that person or community guys trying to
improve for the better
how's your family dealt with this the
most part they've been supporting me and
it was tough nothing I don't see that
but at the end of the day my mom she's
my mom how am I saying and she's never
she never neglected me and I'll still
had a little baby girl I love my mom to
death and I appreciate y'all I support
my family and my mom and coaches and
team they have able to give a sense what
did your mom say when she saw in that
video disappointed she was a
disappointment and I was disappointed in
myself I wish that they'd never happened
warned about the situation it was hard
it was still hard to this day but at the
end of the day I just try not to think
about it and when things come up I'd go
out there and tell the truth but I did
like I said I've been a day wow she's
still my mom but I'll still have baby
boy and she sees me I saw baby boy today
and I love Austin I start be like that
forever where are you going to be on
draft for the draft where are you going
to be when the draft takes place I'm not
sure my family my agent we'll go over
that what a time to be closer and we'll
make a decision from there when do you
think you're going to get drafted Joe
honestly I don't know I can only hope
for the best and that's going in the
first round you haven't been told
because I I don't know if teams are
gonna draft you in the first round even
though you have a first round grade so I
you know I I understand where there's
uncertainty there but it feels like it's
gonna be second or third day for you you
haven't been told anything any specific
specific like I said and I'll call and
hope for the best
that's pretty much about it Joe thanks
for joining us and we appreciate the
time that Joe Mixon the Oklahoma running
back the process is what's fascinating
to me he's too talented to ignore that's
what happened at the pro day now you
might have had teams saying I hope he's
not as good as advertised because then
you can take him off your draft board
that's not gonna happen he deserves a
chance to be able to play if a team says
we're gonna draft you he's got the
talent to be able to do it I know that
we look at this and say boy let's just
do you want your team to draft somebody
like Joe Mixon if he can help your team
that's where you have that dilemma you
know michael vick nobody was gonna hire
michael vick oh there's no way he's
playing again no way there's gonna be
protests and then obviously he he's
still good yeah we see this their
players around the NFL it happens Joe
Mixon just the latest here the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience